good afternoon to everybody thank you
thank you for coming thank you for your
interest and I have a privilege and
honor to hosted a very distinguished
diplomat with amazing diplomatic career
rosemary D Carla dr. rosemary DeCarlo
who is the other Secretary General of
United Nations for political affairs and
peacebuilding
listen.you title of the of rosemary
DeCarlo and peacebuilding so previously
it was separated rosemary Dakar is
American diplomat with a fantastic
career working around the world in
Moscow in Europe everywhere and we met
first in 2007 I was appointed ambassador
Ukraine to United Nations and Rosemarie
was in American mission to United
Nations and she performed fantastically
a duties there being the deputy
ambassador to the United Nations in the
rank of ambassador representing United
States in the Security Council
[Music]
she was everywhere and still she's
everywhere on the monthly basis or even
more frequently she's appearing and in
Security Council to brief on whatever
convene is well on Syria Libya on
Ukraine or whatever so we have a really
important interesting guest today who is
very open to to discuss any questions
about the world of hers which are not
clear they are not well understood even
in the expert community was going on and
of course on division from the United
Nations is very important but of course
the well the openness is limited because
Rosemary's injuries and that's why she
is to balance she is representing the
pas de bourree which depends on the on a
membership
but at any rate she promised to be as
open as possible and we will start with
a short presentation and then
immediately question and answers and
this time you'll be the first to ask her
to give more space to you to ask and
then I will mediate mitigate with my
questions which not very easy even for
me well to formulate them in a way to
have a good answer
so thank you thank you Yuri I don't know
if I can live up to that introduction
very important imported moment of your
of your biography Rosemarie had lectures
at Yale for three years starting in 2015
and well in Jackson Institute and it was
about the multilateral institutions in
the 21st century it will be one of the
questions about the multilateralism and
the role of United Nations in the 21st
century
thank you thank you it's a real pleasure
to be back at Yale as ambassador Sergey
has mentioned they did teach a course
here and multilateral institutions is it
not working and I was here soon after I
had left the US State Department and I
was drawing on my experience
representing the United States in
multilateral fora especially the United
Nations today I'm official of the United
Nations I have not one state that I work
for but 193 States
it's quite different I'm in a department
that I had plays a very central role in
UN efforts to prevent deadly conflict
and build sustainable peace we've got a
global mandate we have political
missions
in Afghanistan Colombia Iraq Libya Haiti
and Somalia
we have envoys that are addressing the
israeli-palestinian conflict Syria Yemen
Lebanon and Myanmar we also have envoys
practicing conflict prevention at a
regional level in East West and Central
Africa and Central Asia and we provide
support to the UN secretary-general in
his engagements across the world when he
uses his good offices to mitigate
conflicts and we're increasingly
involved in work with countries where
there is no formal or no formally manded
peace process or peace operation by
either the UN Security Council or UN
General Assembly so the question the
title of this talk kind of raises the
big questions it's the press of demands
of my job a means that I don't often
think of the bigger picture putting out
daily fires so I'm particularly happy to
have this opportunity to talk with you
and share some of my thoughts with you
today and hear your perspectives on
multilateralism and the future of
multilateralism I mean we're having this
discussion today at a very difficult
time far from having any new world order
or a preserved old order what we see is
unease and uncertainty around the globe
we have intensified competition among
major powers a recession that we face
threats that are more serious than we've
seen in a generation
we have persistent conflict accelerating
climate change and new forms of warfare
derived deriving from technological
change and without international
governance in our core work of conflict
prevention and resolution we're seeing
some negative trends there are three
that stand out and they're sort of
intertwined the first is that conflicts
are increasingly intractable the average
duration of civil wars has risen over
time and it's reflected in the increased
average duration for our peace
operations and
emissions ii in abundance and
fragmentation of non-state actors and
armed groups think of syria conflicts
today often feature complex and
decentralized non-state armed groups
with loose and fluid chains of command
some adopt terrorism as a deliberate
tactic some target the UN complicating
our acceptance as an impartial actor by
all sides and third increased regional
and international involvement conflicts
are increasingly affected by competition
from power for power among regional and
other actors as well as factors such as
migration the priorities of influential
neighbors or international actors can
directly impact on our ability to
resolve conflicts together these factors
contribute to a sense that we've lost
traction on major conflicts also
contribute to increase calls for
isolationism in closed borders and feed
skepticism about multilateral efforts
yet as Secretary General Antonio
Guterres has frequently observed this is
a moment where there is arguably more
need for multilateral cooperation and
collective solutions to a range of
problems that transcend borders and
regions than at any other time in United
the history of the United Nations how do
you explain this and respond to this
central paradox my view is that the
questioning of the relevance of
multilateralism is rooted in divergence
among states in their interpretation of
the basic principles on which United
Nations is based principles that have
defined international cooperation for
the past seven decades this underpins a
tendency to circumvent rules and lead
some states to seek to redefine their
roles in a multilateral system when the
UN was established 74 years ago its
member states committed to the sovereign
equality of all states to refraining
from the use of force and to take in
collective action
regarding threats to international peace
and security these principles are
outlined in the UN Charter to which all
member states of the United Nations all
193 have pledged adherence they were
developed by the victors of the Second
World War still major powers that exist
today but there are new powers now that
we're not weren't part of the creation
of these rules and even those who were
interpret them differently let's take
just one principle that's enshrined in
the Charter in the Charter sovereignty
to many countries sovereignty does not
mean that a state has the absolute right
to do as it chooses it also means that a
state has responsibilities not only to
its own citizens but to other states and
responsibilities not to pollute the
environment to prevent terrorists from
crossing borders to curb the flow of
weapons to abide by international human
rights in humanitarian law but to other
states sovereignty is deemed absolute
this is limited the UN's ability to
prevent and resolve conflicts in many
parts of the world including perhaps
most obviously Syria meanwhile many
people are losing faith in the process
of globalization they feel left behind
around the world we see the rising
appeal of nationalist and populist
voices demonstrations are affecting
countries from the Middle East to Latin
America and the Caribbean and from
Europe to Africa while every situation
is unique one common thread connecting
all demonstrations is a growing deficit
of trust between people and political
establishments this constitutes a rising
threat to the social contract yet not
all the news is bad indeed if we look
back at the high-level week of the
General Assembly this past September
more world leaders than ever before
descended on New York the climate crisis
quite rightly toughed the bill in terms
of their attention and beyond States
generated an extraordinary mobilization
of act
this many of them young demanding change
at the climate action summit now as a
collective body the UN General Assembly
itself counters the idea that
unilateralism could be the answer to the
world's problems what we heard from a
number of member states is that many of
today's challenges cannot be addressed
by one state or a few states alone for
some issues the way forward lies in more
not less International Cooperation to
quote set the secretary-general however
he said many times and I'll quote it is
not enough to proclaim the virtue of
multilateralism we must prove its added
value end quote and I would add and
collective action must be for a defined
purpose based on principles that are
commonly agreed so what do we do
what does multilateralism look like in
practice well the short answer it's just
one word partnerships there's not a
juxtaposition between multilateralism
versus regionalism for example
multilateralism can mean a few states
working together to solve common
problems or an organization like the UN
working with regional organizations or
international financial institutions I
just want to say that my department has
liaison offices with just about all the
major regional organizations out there
certainly the African Union European
Union NATO the Shanghai Cooperation
Organization ASEAN and a number of
others
but these partnerships have to go beyond
States and regional organizations and
beyond intergovernmental bodies to
include civil society the private sector
women's organizations in youth all of
whom make an important contribution to
global international cooperation now
while we're still wrestling wrestling
with existing threats and challenges to
security and to name just a few
migration terrorism proliferation of
weapons of mass destruction arms
transfers we still have new challenges
to address the impact of climate change
on security and the benefits and risks
of new technology I think that you would
probably all agree that not one country
can solve these challenges alone so I'm
gonna end here I'm really keen to hear
your views in particular on how you see
cooperation that is needed to address
today's security challenges and your
role in helping to realize it thank you
thank you did Thank You rosemary used to
be concise and comprehensive at the same
time so now this the space is open for
questions and answers should I start or
you will please okay okay well we have
traditional speakers from Germany
thank you very much ambassador DiCarlo
just to kick off the discussion can you
give us an example from the last 12
months a positive example coming out of
the Security Council that helped resolve
a current conflict
[Music]
yes okay okay I think there are a number
of positive examples that I can cite of
course some are still a work in progress
first of all I think the role that the
UN has played alongside the African
Union in Sudan for the transition in
Sudan is a very positive development
it's work that was done very quietly but
behind the scenes with the strong
support of the UN Security Council we've
seen a transition to what we hope will
be a stable civilian government and a
society that is trying to work through a
number of reforms to not only improve
the economic potential of Sudan but to
deal with the the needs and the desires
of the society so I think that's that's
one that I would cite and again as I
said it's a work in progress and it's
going to demand a lot more attention not
only from the United Nations and the
African Union but from many many member
states to help a Sudan through this
transition this one another one and this
is a one that probably doesn't get a lot
of attention and it would be lasted over
twenty years I think it's 25 actually we
managed to produce an agreement between
Greece and the Former Yugoslav Republic
of Macedonia on Macedonia's name it may
sound as if this was not a conflict that
that was an armed conflict but it
certainly was a huge irritant not only
for North Macedonia and its movement
forward but for the entire Balkan region
so I really think that this shows that
persistence actually can make a
difference our envoy who handle these
negotiations did it for the full 20-some
odd years those are two examples I would
give you I think that
you know highlight the work that can be
done quietly behind the scenes there are
many examples obviously where peace has
not been achieved
I mentioned Syria
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I think that we have to find ways to
do these new new challenges
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they are challenges that really could
cause the stability in various countries
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
um my name is Ron Nabil I'm a former
student of a masters that you have in
your capacity have certainly worked with
the Chinese the Russians to Europeans
I was wondering in light of the great
power competition that you had mentioned
[Music]
delegations from those countries ahead
of their approach towards
multilateralism in your opinion very
from those of the American delegation to
the UN it depends you know it depends
obviously and what the issue is there is
a lot of professing practice achieve
that kind of collective action that is
needed I think you also will see that
countries come at the issue of resolving
conflicts or what is a conflict in very
different perspectives and again Syria I
think is a case in point where there
were a number of countries that felt
that the violations of human rights an
international humanitarian law were
unacceptable in other countries that
felt that indeed a state has the right
to deal as it sees fit with an
insurgency a rebellion just prior to
this position
ambassador Rose Marie de Carlos was the
president of National Association for
American foreign policy and what he
noticed how many efforts she dedicated
to find the dialogue to create a
dialogue between three major powers in
the Yellow Sea China South Korea given
China's over go into that and Japan so
and we had the panel the top political
experts and
Plymouth's there and that helped you
well to earn a well-deserved authority
at that time in the region and so you
are using that now traveling there while
trying to find and to create dialogue
which is absolutely important United
Nations the dialogue is in process well
right you're absolutely right
United Nations is a process and it's I
have to tell you it's very different
being a diplomat for a national service
from being an international civil
servants when you are working for your
national service you know what your
policies are or you think you know what
your policies are and you go for it
right when you're working
internationally you are trying to bring
people together and that is the point
your impartial and your trying to bring
impartial obviously based on certain
values and principles that we all adhere
to as international civil servants and
that is the principles enshrined in the
UN Charter but it is to bring people
together and I have to say that my past
experience both in the nonprofit world
I think in and in teaching here and I'm
listening to the various views of
students as students I had every class I
had was I think would say 50 percent us
and then 50 percent from other parts of
the world really has helped me in the
work that I'm doing now it is not very
easy obviously to be sitting at a table
with such divergent views sometimes but
trying to get something something
together that you can move forward with
in order to let's say at least manage a
situation if not one of the world
leaders and his address to the General
Assembly recently stated the future does
not belong to
globalists mm-hmm everybody knows what's
about yes well no need to give a name or
country and so on and we actually
immediately appeared from from the
membership there can be no return to pre
globalized world so of course this is
this is the competition between the
realities which really they're facing
around the world but so this is about
the what do you dimensionally you're in
your statement how how fragile
multilateralism is but how greatly
supported moderators have as in
community and of course the multilateral
is will gain because a lot of the
challenges the challenges which none of
the even big country can't cope with
below your questions
thank you for thank you for being here
um so the Syrian constitutional
committee met for the first time I think
a few days ago and I was wondering
whether you thought of that as a success
of multilateralism and also just
generally from your position at the UN
how do you work through the challenge of
having to include powers that say maybe
bomb hospitals in multilateral efforts
kind of brokered by the UN and how you
work through that difficulty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and as we have discussions going on on
something that is broader and more major
solve some very nitty-gritty problems
that can improve the situation for
everybody in Syria and for those that
left Syria and hopefully in be an
encouragement for them to feel that they
would be able to return and our view is
the UN you know policy on refugees is
clear and it's it's around the world and
it's not does not just pertain to Syria
but to everywhere else including yep off
that the return of refugees has to be
voluntary safe and dignified otherwise
we are not in a position to encourage
that
I didn't answer the second part of your
question how do you sit down at the
table with people who bomb hospitals you
have no other choice let's put it that
way you have no other choice but to sit
with everybody who's involved in a
particular conflict and try to move
forward and try to reach some kind of
agreement on some basic parameters and
basic principles to help resolve a
situation and move forward to perhaps a
better future thank you professor de
Carla I had a pleasure of being in a
couple of years ago one of the one of
the last classes you were teaching here
thank you for being here
I have a question speaking of
cooperation and dialogue some of the
most important dialogues and human
rights obviously were happening within
the Human Rights Council from which the
US would do as we know in 2018 and how
does it I would like to know from your
vantage point of how does it affect the
dialogues in that area and whether you
see some ways around it and what would
be the next steps and whether there are
some countries that are taking the
leadership in this area thank you edible
that the United States left the Human
Rights Council I think that they were a
major force for good on the council that
said I do see the United States still
working to promote human rights
elsewhere in the UN system and on
specific country issues in particular
that come before the Security Council I
think that there is an absolute need to
in in any conflict situation in
particular but across the board that
human rights has to be a factor and
included very much in there some who are
look more to the political aspect of any
given situation some who look to the
humanitarian but I think you have to
conclude all three and we do see
countries taking the lead when there are
many countries very common
- to human rights that speak out and
drive that and drive policies forward to
ensure that human rights law is observed
in international humanitarian law is
observed new amendments to the Charter I
hope that it will happen
the the council will appear in the text
of the United Nations Charter it is not
their trusty Council which is eroded so
is there but Human Rights Council is not
there and it's reduce its legitimacy
well so a lot of the reforms ahead are
the questions raised
thanks ambassadors for being here
especially as a DeCarlo
there are numerous Security Council
resolutions that are either not adhere
to or that are violated intentionally
that makes the credibility of the
Security Council a bit shaky now granted
that they these resolutions were able to
diffuse major crises but I feel like
these crises are now very percolating or
simmering and so my question to you is
what can be done to remedy this this
conundrum is this major challenge
[Music]
yeah case in point where arms are
flowing into both sides of both warring
parties that clearly the resolution that
was adopted several years ago is
completely ignored it's blatantly
violated and we see pictures on TV and
some of the countries supplying those
arms will tell you that oh there's a
need to observe the arms embargo so it's
really it's quite it's quite amazing
similarly Yemen again arms embargo
that's being violated very clearly I
think this is an issue that has been
raised on a number of occasions both for
countries that have been on the Security
Council for other member states how do
we make these resolutions binding really
binding on member states and there's
been no no way to do so but we seized
the Security Council rights the letter
sometimes if there's a violation I'm
thinking of the case of Lebanon where
there again we have a situation where
arms transfers are in violation of
resolution 1701 and I think a you know
goes to the credibility of the council
and the credibility of the United
Nations now obviously some would say
those who are sort of deniers of
international action and that the
council overreached in adopting some of
these resolutions and then others would
say no we didn't overreach at all it's
just that we have no mechanism really to
call the violators into question and
that is I think a major part of the
problem I don't think we ever will have
that kind of mechanism adopted but I
think that the credibility of a council
is really what is let's say it going to
be necessary in order to see greater
observance of a number of resolutions
where does that credibility come from I
think it comes from council actions and
acting early often they act late
I'm not criticizing the UN Security
Council I was on it and I just you know
saw it from within but sometimes it's
it's hard to get the council to an
agreement to move forward on a
particular issue early enough I think it
also comes from the fact that not only
the council but the United Nations that
until very recently was focused on
putting out fires on resolving conflicts
instead of preventing them I think
that's a huge part of our problem and
this is what really needs to be
addressed the current Secretary General
has made conflict prevention a priority
it is throughout the UN that we're
working on conflict prevention
activities my department does a lot of
conflict prevention a lot of things you
will never read in the news working with
countries that are going through various
crises hoping to defuse those crises
before conflict violent conflict erupts
certainly the work we're doing in the
development area on sustainable
development is all geared at also
helping to ward off conflicts around the
world
I think the Security Council in doing
more early-warning and perhaps working
on issues that where we see we see a
problem coming perhaps would then end up
having at the greater credibility so
when they do have to act they might have
more observance from mark grant and one
of the meetings in the Security Council
he made interesting statement that the
Security Council called you to the
Charter was designed to be a smoke
detector and not just a fire
extinguisher
it is about the the crisis management so
he said about that just it wasn't well
to work on how to prevent conflicts how
to detect them on the early stages and
what should be should be done well not
to to let the the companies to move to
most of the serious Wars and whatever
and my son just mentioned that there is
a number of responsibilities the
ownership of the state ownership to
create a sustainable environment human
rights respect well so this is exactly
what Security Council slowly but moving
they had for the recent two-three years
maybe for three years
for sure what Security Council took it
an agenda the human rights issues as the
source of potential crisis even
including the climate change is there no
because it's existential for some of the
countries like in the in the Pacific but
it's not just about climate change it's
about the people
well great thank you from a spectator
perspective who follows news on the on
the on the UN one good thing that the UN
is a place where people talk a lot but
they do little so how would you um
reassure people that what the UN does is
important for them and they should
believe in multilateral institutions
like the UN and then my second question
is how can you talk less and do more so
what's the reform that's needed to talk
less and do more
probably need to be able to explain
I mean justified to taxpayers why we are
being paid I'm talking about the
Secretariat now they're two different
things there's a secretariat and the
Member States and the various bodies at
the member states are part of but let's
just just talk about the part that I can
have an impact on which is the the
Secretariat I think we do need to do a
better job we're very very quiet about
the conflict prevention we areas we work
in for a number of reasons one we do
want countries to think they resolve the
issue themselves we don't want to go in
and take credit for something even if we
feel that had we not been engaged that
perhaps conflict over a particular
electoral result would have led to
perhaps unrest in the country secondly
as I said there's there is real concern
about interference and domestic affairs
of a country that is something that we
see many member states concerned about
whether it be the UN coming in or a
particular state coming in to resolve a
particular issue and I'm not talking
about military intervention I'm talking
about intervention of other kinds so
we're quiet about that but we do need to
do I think a better job of explaining
what it is we do I'll give you an
example I mean my department has a
standby team of mediators that we deploy
it could be for a lot dealing with
elections I have to say elections are
always a flashpoint in a society that's
not the major problem but that that's
the spark that sets things off
constitution drafting
mediation from a number of issues we're
working on right now mediation and
mitigation efforts on you know dealing
with climate change you know conflicts
between farmers and herders and various
aspects we don't go around publicizing
it very much countries often don't like
the fact that it's you've used them to
explain you know what it is you're doing
on the other hand it is kind of
important for people to know that the
Secretariat is working and doing things
and trying to resolve conflicts as far
as the talk you know there's nothing
wrong with talking I have to say that if
if hammering it out in the General
Assembly or some committee meeting means
that it's by the end of the day you
might have changed a few minds or it
helped defuse a situation there's really
there's nothing wrong with that and it
would be better obviously
if some of the talk resolved you know
resulted in finding a way to have
adherence to certain Security Council
resolutions etc but the fact that people
are talking is it's a good thing thank
you hear me wonderful thank you so much
for coming ambassador in regards to
fires the Amazon rainforest recently and
their refusal of Brazil's presidents
make significant changes to curb the
fires even in face of international
economic sanctions do you think there
could be a multilateral effort to curb
deforestation that would not eventually
disregards Brazil's sovereignty and in
the face that the fires reach critical
levels
in the Amazon rainforest that would lead
to eventual UN peacekeeper intervention
[Music]
problems different let's say new
challenges and so it makes it all the
harder now so again going back to the
comment about how come the Security
Council do better or what could it do or
how could it make its resolutions more
binding on member states when you have
such divergent views in the
international community it's very
difficult somehow there needs to be a
coming together of what the basic
principles that we are all willing to
adhere to I wanted to ask do you think
that the UN Security Council can
maintain its long term legitimacy
without including additional major or
emerging powers as permanent members
remember States to decide I think they
look inclusivity is important there is
no question about it I think that it's
not just a question of adding new
members I think that that you know
obviously would would certainly make the
resolutions that are adopted perhaps
more relevant to certain regions but
it's also a question of again coming
together on what it is the the
international community adheres to what
what are the parameters for their action
and that is going to be the most
critical thing I think in credibility
going forward
thank you so much for coming today
so you guys have spoken a lot today
about structural reform in the need for
reform in the Security Council and I'm
curious how feasible you see submitted
reforms being especially given the veto
powers of permanent members I guess then
[Music]
Russia we have to be five or six you
were fighting for geographical technical
presentation is it caps there because
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have just today we have two things
first of all the United the membership
they are involved in the construction of
the unicorn either they are gathering
here on T major centers or they are
trying to define themselves as the
center of the new war of the central D
so we are in the dynamic speed and still
the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this question is how to convince them
and so there is wink and bringing new
players so there is no answer oh all the
variations
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of course what's going on it's not you
my question next question to be honest
extra peers that city park
multilateralism you should also pay
attention to parable going processes
like ad hoc alliances like midnight area
networks we use them in the past the
first world war he had the conditions of
economies dissemination of the countries
and we have today of course the
performing immediately so the
[Music]
we ilysm a lot and what we really mean I
think is collective action based on a
set of principles that we all agree to
okay a rules-based order now the rules
may be changing but you need agreement
to change them and I think that's that's
the key and sometimes if issues can be
resolved within a country there's a
conflict and the country manages to come
together and that's great
or it can be resolved with a few states
working with a country or it can be
resolved by a regional organization or
group of regional countries working on
an issue all of that is fantastic it
doesn't have to be 193 countries
professing on the issue or they come to
the UN so I think that that is all the
better if it can be resolved at a lower
level of smaller grouping we have a lot
of initiatives and some of them are
absolutely excellent I mean I think that
the point you made about the former
Yugoslavia at the contact group that I
was a part of for a while that worked
together
and I think help to resolve a whole
number of issues related to the breakup
of Yugoslavia we see many groupings
we've got you know friends of Sudan and
working on helping Sudan through its
transition we we see various either
regional organizations or countries
coming together on Haiti on a whole
range of issues and this this is good
but I think there's also a question of
you know it's not just working together
it's question what are you working
together for you know are your
principles grounded you know are we
really paying adherence to you know
international conventions and basic
human rights and civic and political
rights and is that changing and I think
that's something that we have to look at
it's you know what is what are we
putting these collective efforts toward
and obviously I'm not saying that things
are sacrosanct and that you know new
rules are adopted there are changes
maybe to certain systems but that needs
to be there needs to be a consensus or
broad consensus let's put it that way to
do that and I think that we we often say
today copings going off in different
directions and while it may be
multilateral because there are a number
of them perhaps what they're aiming
toward isn't exactly what a lot of us so
it means to cope with that we are to
feel this normative gap and in the six
committee saw the debates are still
going on in general assent
in master de Caro mentioned the
cybersecurity still we have the
institutional gap still there is no
instruments how to manage that
including normative gap as well there is
no D comprehensive convention how to how
to deal with all that so still we have
legitimacy gap with the one of the main
institutions how to bring the
perpetrators to justice
I mean International Criminal Court so
people are in and out in and out so it
is a question of the jurisdiction of the
court but it is relatively new
institution in some of the elements in
even in its statute Ron steroid they
appeared or recently today we mentioned
some with some elements of that for
example the crime of aggression it's a
new element in that and so how how to
judge how to judge whether it is
aggression or any humanitarian
intervention or it is something like
around rights to protect well something
a lot of work to be done by the experts
in the international legal affairs from
Yale University from anywhere to move
ahead with all these gaps in
[Music]
international legislation and so and of
course compliance gap compliance gap is
which exists everywhere because of the
differences both culture ideological
political and so on and how to reach
them through the dialogue what is the
biggest the best platform for that of
course you ready - it's the only
Universal institution of course the
platform's the General Assembly what
whatever in that is real is good but
it's also good to work on the working
level other questions please well
ambassador the color is travelling a lot
so I mostly schedule so recently you you
were in southern Caucasus while in
Turkey before that throughout you know
my career it has not been let's say easy
when I join the State Department I
joined in 1984 and until 1974 a female
diplomat could not be married and remain
in the Diplomatic Service okay so by the
time I joined in 84 there were new there
were a number of women coming and so
there were a lot of there were not many
women let's put it this way in up until
1974 in the US State Department more
came in but they were at lower levels so
it took quite a while for the State
Department to really you know get get on
with the gender equality issue and I
found myself throughout you know my
career trying to ignore the fact of
whether I was female or what I was but
just tried to do my job and eventually
I'm as I said we've got now in the State
Department a large number of female
ambassadors and so forth I never thought
I would make it to ambassador when I
started out my career because they just
weren't any women at that level
it's sort of it just eventually it
happens and women more and more women
became ambassadors the job that I'm in
now at the UN I'm the first woman in 74
years of the United Nations to hold this
position and I didn't think that much of
it I mean having already been an
ambassador and I realized when I came
into the position two things first of
all there's a huge burden on my
shoulders for all the women who were in
the Secretariat who you know want to
make their way up and I couldn't fail
not that I wanted to fail but I
certainly could not fail secondly it was
quite different and challenging at times
because Secretary General Gutierrez has
made a point of gender equality in all
assignments not just senior assignments
and he's done far better because senior
assignments he can name and he's also
been trying to help move women up the
ladder in the Secretariat but there is
still I think a sense of there's a way
you act in a way you do things and what
I found is that most women don't act and
do things in the same way that a man
does in the same position so while my
counterparts were fine because I had a
number of female counterparts as well
it's those that I was managing kind of
saw this unusual American woman and in a
position and and perhaps acting very
differently from a male who had been in
that position over the years so it was
challenging but what I do find in I
think that there is still enough
credibility but the United Nations has
so when I travel and I meet with some
you know a number of mostly male leaders
in countries then I'm taken seriously I
have a message I have a message that not
only I'm carrying for the
secretary-general who has tremendous
credibility
I'm also representing a number of states
with certain positions and it's not as
hard as you might think that said I'm
always aware I mean every so often I'm
aware that of the differences and the
fact that being a female in a position
that had always been had you know given
to a man means that you've got to work
kind of twice as hard and sometimes it
gets a little tiring let's put it that
way
well which is not easy I could imagine
that today the Secretary General is
criticizing through Maduro and to all
she has a meeting with well so this is
the blows you see I'm not raising any
question about the about Ukraine I am
doing this purposely because in 2014 and
15
Rosemarie presided sakura-con so many
times on our issue and so real
persistence how to mobilize the the
United Nations community and including
in the Security Council so where we are
speaking body multilateralism Security
Council is the multilateral deal to have
the majority in the area recall so it's
it's a lot well and that's why I'm
grateful I'm not raising this issue
today because I know that there are
plans to visit Ukraine and to well to
look and to assess the processes there
and then to bring to the
secretary-general the thank you I said
been a loss of interest in
humanitarianism a loss of any real
consensus on it because we see in Europe
and certainly in the u.s. a sort of
hostility to refugees hostility to the
most depressed people and almost a sort
of shutting light up in wanting I get
the impression sometimes people want
these people to suffer maybe that's just
in personal connection anyway is that
the case has there been a loss of
consensus on humanitarianism insists on
humanitarianism as much as defining it
in a different way in some cases I think
that look there there are issues that
one has to take a stand on okay and
certainly supporting you know those who
are vulnerable those who are in need
those who are refugees migrants is
really it's an issue that we have to
stand by
perhaps there you know there's a debate
on measures on degree of assistance
etc but it's clear that we there there
are some principles here that I think
for the United Nations for those of us
who work with me it's in the Secretariat
we've got to be firm about and this is
one of them I mean there are there are
laws conventions governing for example
refugees and these these they're in
existence and they should be certainly
respected the situation of migration you
know there was an attempt at
a broad-based pact on migration which a
number of countries opted out of but
we've got a huge problem with migration
and people are fleeing for very good
reasons and there needs to be a way to
address their concerns so I think that
it is one of the areas I think that what
we've seen in sort of this breakdown of
a social contract among government and
citizens in various parts of the world
has contributed to this I think that you
know the fact that people feel left
behind and therefore are looking to be
as Oh as open and welcoming as they have
been to both refugees and migrants is is
a serious concern I know there was a
question earlier but how do you deal
with you know how do you sit down and
deal with people who are bombing
hospitals you know how do you deal with
dictators well you've got to deal with
them if you want to help you know and a
crisis but then you also have to stand
on principle on some issues and I give
you one example I think that the UN has
been very clear and the
secretary-general has been very clear
about his concerns about how there have
been treated in Myanmar he was very
clear just this past weekend when he was
in Bangkok at the ASEAN summit about the
need from Myanmar to address the issue
of the rahega to create the conditions
inside the Myanmar yeah is that so that
they can return and not just the
physical conditions but the political
conditions so there are you know I think
we have to be those of us who feel
strongly about these issues have to
speak up about it
I'll give you an example I was in a
country recently that was having a big
debate about violence against women some
of them thinking that this was first of
all an internal matter
they shouldn't sign on to various
conventions bad it was cultural okay
and publicly I said and I would say
again that violence against women is not
cultural it's criminal so there are some
there are some things that again as I
may be the diplomat that has to bridge
all the gaps there are some principles I
think that are you know enduring and
undeniable young students are the
greatest they are to have you led some
some remarks to help them to better
understand what's about so graffitis and
migrants all the refugees are migrants
but not all the migrants are refugees in
terms of international law
refugees are more or less protected by
the international conventions migrants
they were not until 2015 when a
journalist my adopted a resolution and
then they launched the process and last
year we had in Morocco we had an
assignment where the Global Compact on
migration was adopted and well to bring
both categories to the more or less
equal position the second important
issue is a responsibility of the parties
involved responsibilities of the
countries of origin the the global
community should work with should work
closer with the country of origin to
help them well to to build this
sustainable environment not to push
people outside of the country so the
first responsibility is there the
responsibility of the countries of the
transition they are to care about the
the migrants refugees they are to define
who is who and then to either to open
doors move ahead your refugees like with
the Syrian migrants running to Europe so
the first countries of Andres they are
to exactly define who is who is not easy
it's costly and so on
and of course country of destination so
if they are permitted legally to enter
in so all the international rules should
work perfectly to help them with the
shelter with the education for their
children medicine so so this is a
complex of the issues and still we still
we have some normative gaps there and of
course we still have the compliance gaps
of all three parties involved in that
country of origin country of transition
in country of destination all of them
should work together so and this global
compact of Morocco is about that so but
I am absolutely confident that still a
lot of work to be done ahead thank you
well first of all welcome back thank you
for coming back so one of the places
where multilateralism at the UN has been
incredibly effective it's an anti money
laundering combating the financing of
terror just in March was it that 2462
was passed and it brought all the anti
money laundering and combating the
financing of terror regulations have
been passed somewhat sporadically and
sort of reinforced them and reiterated
them and sort of celebrated and
reinforced the role of financial action
task force but in the NPO and NGO
community there was some concern because
as these are the humanitarian
organizations that go into conflict
zones increasingly they're finding it
more and more difficult to bank to get
money and aid to people who need it most
the UN in their language said that we
must support humanitarian efforts they
main they must not be disrupted and
that's great language but if it's up to
a bank to assess the value of a client
that's a small Muslim bathe faith-based
NPO and they decide well you're simply
not worth the risk and so we're going to
unbanked or deserve a 60 to 70 percent
of these small npos are do have this
concern is language alone enough can
more be done to protect humanitarian
efforts being undertaken by NPS and NGOs
in this area and I was wondering what
are the debates behind the scene to do
just that words words are not enough
obviously there this this is under
discussion there are you know various
initiatives mechanisms that are being
looked at to try to address this issue
it's a complicated one it's a really
complicated one because it puts then
perhaps the UN in a position
you know verifying a particular NPO or
NGO or not which is not a position we
can we have the capacity to do but we
couldn't agree I couldn't agree with you
more
I mean on the one hand we adopt
something that is really helpful to a
certain end but then it actually hurts
on another aspect of the particular
problem and without having thought
through how we might address that but
that is under discussion and it is it's
a serious problem thank you for coming
back to thank you for sharing you should
all the best success in favor of all of
us and in a global community Thank You
indeed thank you
[Music]